ozzie asks why is your phone always in  the shop my phone is always in shot  because my phone is always with me plus  my adorable sans on there I don't want  to show his pictures Lizzie doesn't let  me share kids photos that much but the  other reason is because if you haven't  heard this is an extension of you as a  human being every one of you rarely is  ever arm's length away from your phone  in every 24 hour window including while  you're sleeping and showering this is an  extension of us this is you know  eventually it's gonna be here and here  and how a man eventually directly in us  this is the extension point and so it's  always with me because I need it to be a  human that's right it sounds sad  plenty comments coming like a but that's  just the way it is